today's advice recommends that we  continue to vaccinate  16 17 year olds who are in at  at risk group as we do now but it also  recommends expanding the offer of the  vaccine  to some younger children with underlying  health conditions that put them at  greater risk  of covert nineteen this includes  children aged 12 to 15 with severe neuro  disabilities down syndrome  immunosuppression and profound or  multiple learning disabilities  mr speaker the jcvi advice also  recommends offering a vaccine to  children and young people aged 12 to 17  who live with someone who is  immunosuppressed  this means we can indirectly protect the  immunosuppressed  who are at higher risk of serious  disease from covert 19 and may not  generate a full immune response to  vaccination  finally the jcbi advice advises  that we should offer the vaccine to all  17 year olds  who are within three months of their  18th birthday  so we can make sure they are protected  as soon as they turn 18.  you